>> Hello this is Robert Skoval and I'm [pause]
giving you my thoughts on the Davos question,
which is how do you improve the world? One
thing I'm studying here while at Davos is
how to improve the water quality around the
world, because there's billions of people
who don't have the clean water that I do to
drink every day or use in their fields or
use to take bath in. And if you don't have
clean water, everything else doesn't quiet
measure up. It doesn't matter that you have
a cell phone or a computer if you don't have
clean water. doesn't matter that you have
food to drink, if you don't get clean water
you're gonna be too sick to eat food or get
out in the fields and work or hang out with
your family so. If there's one thing that
I think we can do to improve the world it's
think about how to make clean water. There's
some innovations here that I heard about so
far that are pretty interesting. One guy built
a tricycle that while you drive it around
or ride it around. It is actually filtering
water for your family's use. That's pretty
interesting. Anyways, that's it from Davos.